I am inevitable
And I. Am. Iron Man.
hi everyone they're dropping more
deleted scenes from Avengers and games
will break it all down this obviously
coming from the end of the movie the I
am Iron Man
iconic scene in the way they handle Iron
Man's death scene this is just the
beginning there's a whole bunch of other
deleted scenes and other things they're
going to be dropping the next couple of
days
so of course I'll be doing videos for
all that stuff be sure to subscribe to
get everything if you're brand new to
the channel we're also doing an Avengers
endgame blu-ray giveaway I'll explain at
the end of the video after the very
iconic I am Iron Man scene of him
snapping his third improvised Infinity
Gauntlet
because remember Santos was wearing the
second gauntlet so the one that Iron Man
cleverly steals all the Infinity stones
and when Thanos isn't looking is the
third version of the gauntlet but the
really cool thing is that because the
stark tech gauntlet that he made in the
Avengers base that the Hulk used to snap
everyone back is core Iron Man
technology the nanites that he uses to
make his current marked 85 Iron Man suit
that he's wearing in this big final
battle could just incorporate whatever
other designs from other stark tech that
he wants that's the whole basis for the
nanites it can become any armor that he
wants if he wanted to wear the
Hulkbuster the nanites would just
reconfigure into the Hulkbuster if he
wanted to use the proton cannon
they would just reconfigure into the
proton cannon from the comics so Thanos
and his armies blow away as dust he
collapses and some of his closest what
you would consider family members core
Iron Man characters get to say their
goodbyes
mostly Pepper Potts because they are
married they have a child Morgan Stark
together of all the characters she's
been with him the longest since he was a
douche way before he ever wound up
becoming Iron Man the first Iron Man
film war machine because he's Iron Man's
oldest friend that he still has around
in spider-man because he kind of
unofficially adopted spider-man in the
MCU there were so many memes about that
after spider-man homecoming in the
deleted scene while this is happening
there goodbye scene you see all the
Avengers in the guardians on the
battlefield take a knee starting with
Hawkeye Marvel is calling the deleted
scene Avengers take a knee but you have
a lot of other characters that aren't
Avengers on this battlefield here so
Hawkeye takes a knee Black Panther takes
a knee Captain Marvel star-lord nebula
Valkyrie ant-man
Captain America the cameras just like
slowly panning forward as everyone's
taking a knee one at a time Doctor
Strange Shuri
a koi a Drex and mantas isn't quite sure
what to do here like you could see her
she's waiting to take a knee like what
are we doing here why are we taking a
knee okay I'll just I'll do it too
because everyone else is doing it her
big social disorder in reading social
situations is supposed to be because she
was raised in almost complete isolation
by ego the Living Planet which they
mostly use for comedy because Drax is so
literal so when you put them together in
a scene it just winds up being really
silly what exactly is it that they do
kick names take ass but then as the
camera moves forward to nebula she's
like thanks but no thanks I'll pass and
just completely bails on them to steal a
ship and take off before they start
cleaning up the battlefield and have the
funeral so you could probably assume why they deleted this scene it kind of slows
things down in there a couple of funny
moments during it when it's not supposed
to be funny this is supposed to be a
really serious somber scene like
everyone's kind of crying their eyes out
are really sad that Ironman just died
and you have mantis kind of making a
little joke in the background nebulous
reaction almost winds up being kind of a
funny moment so what kind of ruins the
scene just a little bit that's why in
the original version of the scene they
go straight from Spider Man Pepper Potts
and war machine saying goodbye to Iron
Man to the slightly less sad musical
montage of all the reunions all over the
world and the funeral scene intercut
with iron man's voice overall about
wanting everyone to be hopeful about the
future all these scenes of the reunions
are happening almost immediately after
the funeral so only about a week or so
has passed since everyone has gone home from the battlefields here and had the
funeral spider-man reunites with Ned
Leeds at the start of their school year
or the restart of their school year
because as we learn at the beginning of
spider-man far from home in a really
funny moment everyone got snapped after
they had already taken their midterm
exams but they made them completely
restart the school year from the
beginning anyway when they were blip
that was mostly meant to be a funny
moment and it was totally hilarious at
the beginning of far from home but the
other their timeline reasons for doing
that too because they want to keep
spider-man in high school during all of
his trilogy movies in the MCU so if he
goes to college it won't be till the
next trilogy of spider-man movies
ant-man the wasp in the now adult Cassie
Lang get their scene Emma Furman
actually said that she's pumped to be in
more Marvel movies but would not say
anything about ant-man and the wasp
three three
and Kevin Feige didn't announce it at
the Marvel phase for comic-con panel
this is because right now it's probably
going to wind up being a Marvel phase 5
movie and they were only announcing
Marvel phase 4 movies with the exception
being for blade the Fantastic Four movie
that he wanted to let everyone know
they're working on in x-men movies like
yes we just got the Fox character so of
course we're working on those movies
they may reveal more of those Marvel
phase 5 movies at the d23 panel in
August I know everybody just wants to
know because they've already completely
planned out Marvel phase 5 in addition
to Marvel phase 4 but I'll do a video
for that whenever they make their
announcement or whatever it is that they
reveal it's not going to happen till the
end of August so it's still going to be a
couple weeks before we find out you get
the scene a black panther shuri in their
mother back in Wakanda we also know that now they're making black panther - of
course it is also going to wind up being
another Marvel phase 5 movies so it
won't happen till at least 2022 pretty
much everybody else at the funeral scene
will come back in their own movie like
the guardians I don't know about general
Ross in the background because he
represents the authority figure working
for all the collective world governments
that want to regulate superheroes which
is going to be an even bigger thing once
x-men start to proliferate all over the
MCU but pretty much everybody's standing in this scene is going to come back in
their own solo film guardians the Thor
except for the Hulk obviously because
they still can't do a whole movie
because Universal has the distribution
rights even though Marvel has the
production rights back
so they actually got the production
rights back to make a Hulk film way
after the angley movie happened that's
how they wound up making the Incredible
Hulk with Edward Norton way back during
Marvel phase 1 for the weird situation
is is that Universal retains the
distribution rights and right now Disney
doesn't want to release a movie that
they have to let somebody else
distribute because it means that another
studio winds up earning a bunch of money
the only reason they do that for
spider-man is just because they have to
in spider-man is such an important
popular character a lot of you also
asking now what about a Hulk TV show
couldn't they do that if they weren't
going to do a Hulk movie they're doing all
these Avengers phase 4 movies if they're
going to spend a hundred million dollars on each of them couldn't they spend that
money doing a Hulk TV show I still think
that because of the way the hope moves
and the things that he does the way he
just completely destroys everything he's
one of the more expensive
CG characters within the MCU for those
of you asking about Jennifer Walters
she-hulk are they ever going to do she-hulk
I believe the situation with the movie
rights is the same with she-hulk so I
think that they'll get to her eventually
but it probably won't be till Marvel
phase 5 Marvel phase 6 right now I'm
still working on my Doctor Strange -
Scarlet Witch plot teaser video and
villain break down that video should
post later tonight or early tomorrow if
I don't finish in time there's a whole
bunch more Marvel phase 4 and Avengers
endgame deleted scenes so all those
videos will just come over the next
couple of days but if you have any big
questions that you want me to make
videos about just let me know in the
comments the avengers endgame blu-ray
giveaway will just keep going on for the
next couple of weeks so as long as
you're subscribed to my channel and
you're leaving comments about the
Avengers or whatever the different
videos are about you have officially
entered the giveaway and when I name
winners I put their comments in the
video so just keep your eyes peeled for
that but while you wait for everything
click here for the Avengers endgame
bloopers and gag reel and click here for
that big Marvel face for Comic Con panel
breakdown with all the movies and shows
that are coming up thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight!